grab that microphone cuz we get we can't
hear you without it it's heavy I'm happy
to put it down for a second have you
digested what this moment means and the
people you beat like Bill Hader owns
this he literally owns this category
right and they say boom you win what
goes through your mind at that moment
it's still going through my mind I think
I'm just really I'm super humbled super
excited that a show of this size can can
make that impact I mean the people in
that category are people that I love
watching so it's really it's it's
exciting that was a beautiful
politically correct answer but really
what went through your mind when you
want I was like
there you go Michael Douglas don't mess
with me also the message that it sends
to the world today this is an important
message that goes out especially in the
political climate of what's going on
right now
yeah I think it just shows that we need
to be talking about these stories you
know for so long people have been
talking about Muslims a show like mine
allows you to talk with Muslims and and
just a very specific type of Muslim to
you know there are so many others and so
many other stories that need to be told
and and it's really exciting to be on
the forefront of some of that hey by the
way it almost feels a little stupid that
we have to talk about things in that man
I know
no of course and and it's just part
hopefully we won't have to have this
conversation in in ten years right yeah
and but it but it's whatever it takes
holy cow you've won a Golden Globe crazy
who has called you who's looking for you
right now who's been blowing you up dude
I have my phone on the table my sister
is here with me so so it up-to-there but
I you left your phone on the table yeah
ma'am so don't want to talk to you right
now now man no oh my gosh your family
everybody you haven't talked to anybody
nah I'm gonna talk to you man well I
mean this is the only guy this is an
important interview okay so now where's
the gold in the logo where do you put
these things of our mom it comes free
that's it mom gets it yeah what does
this mean to your parents do you think I
mean it means a lot to them you know my
my
my dad moved to this country with no
money you know I mean it's a great key
he we talked about this in my show a
little bit we show a slice of it but my
dad bought a tape recorder and he'd
record himself and send it to his family
because he couldn't afford phone cards
like that's the like that's the level of
sacrifice and so to be able to you know
tell part of that story and then
recognize what something like this is
she's pretty unbelievable how emotional
do you think it is for a man who came to
this country and had to tape record his
messages to them how do you how
emotional you think it is for him right
now when he sees his kid invented this
thing about them yeah yeah about them
what do you think resonates in their
mind like how do how do you digest that
yeah it's a lot but I think I think
they're proud you know I think they're
proud it's really it's really it's
amongst a lot of things but yeah okay
how does tonight play out man probably
meet up with Michael Douglas you know
tell him it was a fair shot he tried his
best DK you know yeah I gotta just be
like look I know you tried but what what
can you do you know it's just it's just
what happened happened see you next time
you know so I'll try and console him for
a little bit and then hang out my sister
by the way where's your sister she's out
there she's you left your sister because
somebody you've got to go get your
sister I know there we go
she's losing her mind right now she's
probably walking in your phone she know
your passcode yeah we look like she
might be able to face that here listen
congratulations this is a momentous
moment I hope you take it in thank you
and what you've done and would it mean
value and how this will change the
culture of the world thank you so much
[Music]